Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous êtes-vous déjà rendu
dans les îles de Polynésie française ?
Avez-vous exploré
les verdoyantes îles de la Société ?
Les lagons bleu turquoise
des Tuamotu et des Gambier ?
Les isolées mais magnifiques
Australes et Marquises ?
Y avez-vous découvert
ces hommes et ces femmes
qui ont hérité d’un héritage
patrimonial et culturel
et vous l’ont partagé
avec une bienveillance
qui leur est propre ?
Je suis fonctionnaire communal,
je travaille
dans la transition alimentaire
et pour ce faire,
j’ai la chance de me rendre
dans de nombreuses îles polynésiennes.
Au fur et à mesure
de mes déplacements, de mes missions,
je me suis rendu compte d’une chose,
c’est que nos îles, elles sont magnifiques
et elles sont toutes uniques.
Uniques par leur environnement,
par leur culture, par leur population.
Néanmoins,
malgré cette incroyable diversité d’îles,
il existe un point commun
entre toutes ces îles,
et ce point commun,
c’est le taux de surpoids et d’obésité
qui règne sur notre population.
L’avez-vous également remarqué ?
Oui ?
Vous êtes-vous demandé
pourquoi sommes-nous
dans une telle situation ?
Et quelles en sont les conséquences ?
Je me suis posé la question.
Et la réponse n'est ni simple ni unique.
C’est un ensemble de facteurs
qui font que nous sommes
dans une telle situation :
facteur génétique, modèle social,
habitudes alimentaires, laisser-aller,
coût des denrées alimentaires
et plein d’autres.
Le lien entre tous ces facteurs,
c’est l’alimentation.
Et c'est ce dont je vais
vous parler ce soir.
L'alimentation.
Pour cela,
je vais vous prendre l’exemple de Teva.
Teva, c’est un Polynésien
comme tant d’autres.
Et il se lève très tôt le matin
pour aller travailler.
Il commence sa journée
par le traditionnel café pain beurre,
parfois accompagné de firi firi,
parfois de fruits.
Teva, il va se rendre au travail
et vers 9 heures, 9 heures et demie,
il va commencer à avoir un petit creux.
Du coup, que va faire Teva ?
Il va ouvrir un paquet
de biscuits sucrés ou de gâteaux,
ça lui permettra de tenir jusqu’à 11 h 30,
l’heure à laquelle, avec ses collègues,
ils se rendent à leur snack préféré.
Et là, qu’est-ce qu’il fera ?
Il commandera son fameux hachis
frites double sauce.
Ça, ça lui permettra de tenir
jusqu’à la fin de la journée,
assurer ses missions.
Sa journée de travail,
elle se termine vers quelle heure ?
Vers 17 h, quand, après 1 heure
de déplacement, il arrive chez lui,
et là, qu’est-ce qu’il a envie de faire ?
Comme tout le monde !
Se poser dans le canapé,
ouvrir un petit paquet de
biscuits salés ou de chips.
Juste avant le dîner.
Le dîner arrivera vite.
18 h 30, 19 h.
Et là, le menu dépendra d’une chose :
si on est en début ou en fin de mois.
Pourquoi ?
En début de mois, il voudra
faire plaisir à sa petite famille.
Du coup, que va-t-il faire ?
Il va les emmener à la roulotte.
Et là, il aura le choix traditionnellement
entre trois types de menus.
Le premier, une viande accompagnée
de frites ou de riz.
Le second, un plat chinois,
ma’a tinito, chow mein
et le troisième, du poisson,
cuit, cru, lui-même accompagné
de riz ou de frites.
En fin de mois ? Plus compliqué !
Il faut se serrer la ceinture.
Là, avec sa petite famille, Teva,
il va avoir tendance à privilégier
des repas qui coûtent moins cher.
Du coup, pourquoi pas un petit
paquet de soupe instantanée ?
Vous savez, soupe bleu,
nuit chinoise, tout ça…
Ce que je ne vous ai pas dit,
dans toute cette journée,
c’est que Téva, il n’aura pas bu d’eau,
pas un seul verre d’eau.
Il va boire du café,
Il va boire du jus, il va boire des sodas,
va même boire des bières peut-être,
mais pas d’eau.
Ce que j’essaie de vous expliquer
à travers l’exemple de Teva,
c’est que Teva, il mange trop.
Et il mange trop gras,
trop salé, trop sucré.
Et ça, ça a des incidences
directes sur Téva.
Comme 70% de la population polynésienne,
Teva est en état de surpoids.
Et si Teva continue un petit peu
à se faire plaisir, à se laisser aller.
il va devenir obèse
comme 40% de la population.
Et ça, ça entraîne des choses,
de mauvaises choses.
Des maladies,
l’accumulation, pourquoi pas,
de cholestérol,
le diabète de type 2,
la goutte…
Plus grave, les maladies cardiovasculaires
ou les tragiques cancers.
D’un point de vue humain,
c’est déjà terrible.
Mais si on prend un peu de recul
et qu’on analyse aussi les conséquences
environnementales de cette alimentation,
là aussi, il y a des problèmes.
Dans la journée de Teva
que je viens de vous décrire,
seulement deux choses
étaient issues de nos îles.
Seulement deux choses étaient locales.
Ces choses, c’est l’éventuel fruit
du matin et le potentiel poisson du soir.
Le reste vient d'où ?
Le reste vient d’où ?
Ça vient d’ailleurs,
ça vient de l’étranger,
ça vient de nombreux pays :
la Nouvelle-Zélande, l’Australie,
la Chine, les États-Unis
et même la lointaine France.
Alors oui, l’exemple de Teva,
il est caricatural.
Pourtant,
il est le véritable reflet du système
alimentaire polynésien.
76% de ce que nous consommons
vient de l’étranger.
76% !
Qu’est-ce que ça signifie ?
C’est simple.
Trois quarts de ce que vous mettez
dans votre assiette
fait a minima 8 000 kilomètres
en avion ou en bateau
pour s’y retrouver.
8 000 kilomètres a minima.
Ça, qu’est-ce que ça entraîne ?
Ça entraîne deux choses
d’un point de vue environnemental :
un impact carbone démesuré.
Quand on fait des milliers de kilomètres
pour se rendre d’un point A à un point B,
ça nécessite de l’énergie fossile,
mais également un autre problème.
On en parlait plus tôt.
La génération de déchets, on ne sait
même plus quoi en faire dans nos îles.
Alors à Tahiti, oui,
on a quelqu’un qui le gère.
Mais allez aux Tuamotu,
allez aux Marquises,
vous verrez des dépotoirs partout.
Devant les gens, parfois collectifs,
mais ils sont partout.
Si on prend encore un peu plus d’ampleur,
et qu’on analyse la situation économique
que cela entraîne,
on est encore dans le non-sens.
Quel système durable pourrait se dire
qu’il va investir 76% de son panier
économique alimentaire
dans des multinationales étrangères.
Seulement 24% dans l'économie locale.
Quel système se dirait durable
dans ces conditions-là ?
Alors oui, je vois
des têtes qui se hochent.
La plupart d’entre vous ici présents
à l’Intercontinental ce soir,
ne sont pas concernés
par l’exemple de Teva.
Parce qu’on ne va pas se mentir,
la plupart d’entre nous
avons les moyens financiers
pour se payer un régime alimentaire autre,
un régime alimentaire
sain, local, durable.
Mais ça, ce n’est pas
le cas de la majorité.
Moins de 30% de la population
polynésienne, aujourd’hui,
a accès à un tel régime alimentaire,
un régime alimentaire sain.
Moins de 30%.
Ce que j’essaye de vous dire aujourd’hui,
c’est que le système alimentaire
polynésien n’est pas durable.
Au travers des exemples
que je vous ai donnés,
vous avez pu voir qu’aucun
des grands piliers, économique, social,
environnemental, du développement
durable n’est respecté.
Aucun des trois grands piliers.
Notre population se rend malade.
On investit à l’étranger
au lieu d’investir en local
et environnementalement parlant,
je n’en parle même plus.
Alors c'est là où je vois
vos têtes de consternés.
Vous devez vous dire :
« Mais normalement, un talk TEDx,
n’est-il pas censé être positif ? »
Vous avez bien raison,
je n’ai pas terminé.
Parce que pour changer une habitude
personnelle ou un modèle social,
c’est souvent la première étape
qui est la plus difficile.
Et cette première étape, quelle est-elle ?
C’est celle de conscientiser le problème,
puis de développer la volonté
de le résoudre.
Et ça, en Polynésie française,
ça y est, on l’a passée, cette étape.
De nombreux acteurs agissent
dès aujourd'hui.
Je pense tout d’abord à la puissance
publique qui, à travers son pays,
se lance dans un grand plan
de transition alimentaire
qui veut mettre en place
des centaines de projets
sur les dix prochaines années
afin de favoriser l’agriculture locale,
le transport inter-îles,
mais également augmenter
la consommation de produits locaux.
Je pense à la grande loi du pays,
du premier août 2022,
qui est venue imposer aux cantines
du premier et du second degré
de mettre jusqu’à 50% de produits locaux
dans l’assiette de nos enfants.
50% de produits locaux,
n’est-ce pas formidable ?
Je pense également aux communes
qui, pour respecter ces taux de la loi,
créent de plus en plus
de jardins potagers communaux
pour alimenter directement
les cantines scolaires
et faire en sorte que les enfants
mangent de mieux en mieux.
Je pense aussi à leur politique
d’éducation au goût
des nouvelles générations,
à leurs projets de réduction
du gaspillage alimentaire
et de valorisation des biodéchets.
Mais ils ne sont pas seuls.
La sphère privée, elle aussi, bouge.
En effet, les entreprises
et les entrepreneurs,
ils agissent.
Aujourd’hui à Tahiti, on a la chance
d’avoir des traiteurs, par exemple,
qui proposent des repas 100% locaux,
100% végétariens
et parfois même 100% végans.
On a des entrepreneurs qui se lancent
dans l’agro-transformation,
qui essayent de faire en sorte
d’augmenter la durée de vie
de nos produits locaux en prédécoupant,
en cuisant, en congelant,
le taro par exemple,
ce qui permet d’en envoyer
dans toutes les îles polynésiennes,
mais également en réduisant l’importation,
en proposant des alternatives locales.
Je pense à la farine de uru,
de taro, de manioc
qui peut remplacer, finalement,
la farine de blé.
Il y a des concepts aussi qui sont créés.
Comme le village de l’alimentation
et de l’innovation
qui a rassemblé l’année dernière
des milliers de personnes
de toutes les générations
pour les sensibiliser sur le manger local,
le manger durable et le manger sain.
La société civile,
elle n’est pas en reste.
Les individus et les associations
agissent au quotidien.
Nous avons de plus en plus d’associations
qui organisent des conférences
comme celle où nous sommes
ce soir tous ensemble,
mais aussi des associations
qui organisent des marches pour le climat.
Vous verrez de plus en plus des slogans
promouvant une alimentation saine,
locale et moins carnée.
Il y a des individus
qui vont dans les écoles.
et qui sensibilisent directement
nos enfants.
Toutes ces sphères,
la puissance publique, la sphère privée
et la société civile sont des maillons,
les maillons d’une chaîne qui veut porter
le poids de la transition alimentaire.
Sauf que le poids
de cette transition est colossal.
Et il manque un maillon
dans ce que je viens de décrire.
Et ce quatrième maillon,
Mesdames, Messieurs,
c’est nous.
Nous.
Vous savez, ceux qui sont qualifiés
souvent comme des consom'acteurs.
Ceux qui, par leurs moyens financiers,
humains, matériels, temporels,
peuvent décider d’investir
dans un modèle ou dans un autre.
On a notre part à jouer là-dedans.
Alors oui, je vous entends déjà dire :
« C’est plus simple à dire qu’à faire. »
Et vous avez tout à fait raison.
Néanmoins, il y a plein de petites actions
que l’on peut ajouter dans notre quotidien
pour réduire notre impact alimentaire.
Je pense notamment à l’exemple de Teva
qui se rend avec sa petite famille
à la roulotte.
Si je l’avais en face de moi,
je lui dirais : « Teva,
prends plutôt le poisson. »
Eh oui, le poisson vient de moins loin.
« Essaye de prendre des frites de uru
plutôt que des frites qui viennent
de l’autre côté de la planète. »
Je vais m’adresser à ceux
qui ont un petit terrain : « Plantez !
Commencez par des herbes aromatiques,
enchaînez peut-être avec des légumes,
puis enfin des arbres fruitiers. »
Je pense à ceux qui sont
des consom'acteurs.
Quand vous voulez acheter
des fruits ou des légumes,
au lieu d’aller en grandes surfaces,
allez directement chez les producteurs.
Vous leur permettrez
d’être mieux rémunérés.
Ceux qui ont les moyens financiers,
achetez du local, achetez du bio,
ce ne sera que meilleur pour votre santé.
Il y a plein d'autres exemples.
Par manque de temps, je m’arrêterai là.
Néanmoins, je ne peux que vous inviter,
chacun d’entre vous,
à aller vers ceux, dans votre famille
votre entourage,
qui se bougent déjà pour mettre en œuvre
cette transition alimentaire.
Ils seront une source d’inspiration,
vous encourageront
à vous-même vous lancer et vous engager.
Je vais m’adresser également
à un public assez particulier
qui est ici présent ce soir.
C'est les parents.
Oui, les parents qui sont ici présents
dans cette salle,
ceux qui nous regardent
à travers leurs écrans.
En tant que parent, n’avons-nous pas
la responsabilité de nourrir
sainement nos enfants
pour qu’ils puissent grandir
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
afin de vivre une vie palpitante ?
Pour ça,
je vous invite fortement
à faire goûter à vos enfants,
dès le plus jeune âge, des fruits,
des légumes, des tubercules,
les produits de nos lagons.
C’est dans les premières années
que notre palais se développe le plus.
C’est là où il faut goûter.
Pour conclure,
j’ai cherché une phrase
qui viendrait  vous résumer
que le système alimentaire
polynésien aujourd’hui,
il n’est pas durable.
Une phrase qui viendrait vous rassurer.
Parce qu’aussi terne que soit ce constat,
des acteurs se bougent déjà
pour l’améliorer.
Une phrase qui viendrait vous inviter
en tant que quatrième maillon
de cette fameuse chaîne, à vous bouger,
à investir
dans cette transition alimentaire.
Une phrase pour vous encourager.
Mais malgré des heures,
des jours et même des semaines,
cette phrase miraculeuse,
je ne l’ai pas trouvée.
Alors, je conclurai simplement
par une chose :
ensemble, changeons
nos habitudes alimentaires
pour assurer un avenir durable
à notre population et à nos îles.
Mauruuru.
(Applaudissements)